Ná mì trên nân truyến thủ tưởng Thái Lan, Anujin, Chà Vira Côn, Cộng Nội Các, đã trình bài tuyên mô chính xác chú cô hội,
công mô chính trình nghĩ sự khẩn cấp của mấy lâm điểm.
Chỉu phụ mới nhớ nạn tình như nhận này được coi là bất tổng quanh dịch,
mối áp lực tự kinh tế, xa hội, chính trị và đẹp chính trị, đời họ sẽ phát kịt thời.
Chẳng liên vực kinh tế, tế biển phát khẩn cấp tập trung ngờ việc khói phục chính trình đồng chi trả,
giảm giá hàng thiết yêu, khoa đỏ hối trở đời sống hư dân.
Thái Lan cũng đầm một tiêu điều trình chính xác thú hồn đầu tư,
ư tiên lính vực công nghệ cao, nhằm suy chiến án lực cạnh trang trung mối cạnh
tăng thẳng thường mạy toàn cầu.
Về áp nình chính phục căng kết giả của chính chấp biển dưới với công buổi tría,
bằng biển phát khóa mình và đẹp án toàn trưng hư dân khu vực biển dưới.
Ngoài ra, chuy trình nghĩ sự cũng bao gồm cửa ư tiên như sửi nợ của xa,
chân ám nạn cơm bà bảo vệ mua trường và cải cơm phát,
kết thú phát biều thủ tường án tình khẳng lình sẽ hành động với tình thần mình bạch chính chực,
đặt lợi đình nước lên hàng đầu.